This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个充满奇特现代的世界里，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及如何培养适应力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“%”，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, we are going to be talking about a pretty significant emotion, a very core emotion and experience, both in our 20s and I think beyond, and that is the experience of panic, of fear, intense alarm, terror, whatever you want to call it, but specifically, we are going to be addressing panic attacks, that sudden onset of extreme dread and anxiety that engulfs us, normally in response to some threat in the environment. whether that is real or perceived.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析的是你二十岁的心理学。今天，我们将讨论一个相当重要的情绪，一个非常核心的情绪和体验，无论是在我们的20多岁还是我认为之后的人生中，那就是恐慌的体验，恐惧、强烈的惊恐、恐怖，无论你想怎么称呼它，但具体来说，我们将讨论恐慌发作，那种突然爆发的极度恐惧和焦虑，通常是为了应对环境中的某种威胁，无论这种威胁是真实存在的还是感知到的。
Panic attacks are a terrible sensation, really. And I'm saying that as, of course, someone who has had, for years, experienced these as kind of part of my daily, weekly, monthly life. Often in response to things that I couldn't even identify, or which was so ambiguous and non-warisome in hindsight, that I felt like I didn't even know why these, panic attacks were occurring in the first place. They were just coming out of the blue, really, in that sense of confusion.
说实话，恐慌发作是一种可怕的感觉。我是作为当然经历过这些的人来说的，多年来，这些体验已经成为我日常生活、每周、每月生活的一部分。通常是为了应对我甚至无法识别的事情，或者在事后看来是如此模棱两可、毫不担忧的事情，以至于我觉得自己甚至不知道为什么这些恐慌发作会首先发生。它们真的是毫无征兆地出现，带来那种困惑感。
And more specifically, I think a lack of control felt equally scary. And I think this idea or this sensation that I couldn't control what my mind or my body was choosing to do, kind of kept that cycle continuing because I began to fear the sensation and fear the fear of a panic attack rather than anything in particular. And the more I think I began to actually learn about why that was, how that happened, what a panic attack is, the more I really felt that sense of control I needed. Not just a control over the bodily sensations that accompany this experience, the racing heartbeat, the shortness of breath, the tingles, the mental spiral.
更具体地说，我认为缺乏控制感同样让人感到害怕。而且我认为这种想法或感觉，即我无法控制我的大脑或身体选择做什么，在某种程度上让这个循环持续下去，因为我开始害怕这种感觉，害怕恐慌发作的恐惧，而不是任何特定的事情。而且我认为，当我开始真正了解为什么会这样、这是如何发生的、什么是恐慌发作时，我越是真正感受到我所需要的掌控感。不仅仅是控制伴随这种体验的身体感觉，比如心跳加速、气短、麻刺感、精神上的恶性循环。
but I also just increased this feeling of capability. I felt like I had a newfound ability to cope and to see panic as no more than just an emotion, an evolutionary response to my environment, an alarm system that was unfortunately broken for me. And although it was quite debilitating for a while, I used to get these really intense week or month-long periods where I was having them twice a day consistently.
但我其实也增强了这种能力感。我觉得自己有了一种全新的应对能力，能把恐慌仅仅视为一种情绪、一种对环境的进化反应、一个不幸对我来说坏掉的警报系统。虽然它在一段时间内相当让人虚脱，我曾经有过非常强烈的一周或一个月的时期，连续每天发作两次。
I do now feel like I'm at this point where I understand why that happened and I learnt from it. And I learnt the best ways I think of dealing with this very weird sensation, with this very unique type of fear. And we're going to talk about it today. I want to talk you through my best tips for coping, tell you about what I've learned, and kind of provide you with the ultimate guide to panic attacks. We're going to discuss the true causes, some of the misconceptions, the distinction between panic and anxiety. And why it is that some people, perhaps like you and I, have this weird, misguided, malfunctioning alarm system. I always think that psychoeducation talking about the problem is such a valuable tool to begin with when it comes to anything, really,
我现在确实觉得我到了这样一个地步：我明白了为什么会发生这种情况，并且从中吸取了教训。我认为我也学到了应对这种非常奇怪的感觉、这种非常独特的恐惧的最佳方法。我们今天要讨论这个。我想和你聊聊我应对的最佳建议，告诉你我学到了什么，并为你提供一份关于恐慌发作的终极指南。我们将讨论真实的起因、一些误解、恐慌与焦虑的区别。以及为什么有些人，也许就像你我一样，会有这个奇怪的、被误导的、 malfunctioning的警报系统。我一直认为，谈论这个问题的心理教育在处理任何事情时都是一个非常有价值的起点，
because how can we feel in control of our panic if we don't even know, where it's coming from. If we don't even understand its emotional, biological, psychological origin, when we understand that psychology, we no longer feel like panic attacks are some big, scary visitor that we can't get rid of. They're just something a lot more simple and tame. They are a series of bodily and mental reactions that have just gotten their wires crossed. It's this combination of sensations that is meant to be helpful, but right now, It's not. And that is all that it is. It is not some big physical thing that is going to come in and ruin your life. You are not going to pass away. You are not going to die. You are not going to
因为如果我们甚至不知道恐慌从何而来，我们怎么能对恐慌感到有控制力呢。如果我们甚至不理解它的情感、生物学、心理学根源，当我们理解了这种心理学，我们就不会再觉得恐慌发作是什么我们无法摆脱的、巨大而可怕的访客。它们只是更简单、更温和的东西。它们是一系列刚好搭错线的身体和精神反应。这种感觉的组合本意是好的，但现在，它不是。这就是它的全部。它不是什么会突然出现并毁掉你生活的巨大的身体问题。你不会过去的。你不会死的。你不会
feel like this forever. You will exhaust yourself. You will get through this. So let's talk about it. Before we start a little PSA that the final five, six minutes of this episode are a short relaxation audio if you are having a panic attack right now. So if you want to listen to that, please see the timestamp in the description. And if you are returning to this episode here as your reminder to feel free to skip ahead if that is what you're here for. But let's get started. Learning to deal with overwhelming and intense emotions is kind of part of our journey as humans for some more than others.
永远这样感觉。你会精疲力竭的。你会挺过去的。所以我们来谈谈吧。在开始之前，有一个简短的公共服务公告：本集的最后五、六分钟是一段简短的放松音频，如果你现在正在经历恐慌发作。所以如果你想听那个，请查看描述中的时间戳。如果你回到这一集作为提醒，如果你想跳过，请随意跳过，如果你是为了这个来的话。但我们开始吧。学会处理压倒性的强烈情绪可以说是我们作为人类旅程的一部分，对有些人来说比对其他人更多。
But I also don't think that the end goal, when we're talking about panic attacks or any emotion that is scary, I don't think that the end goal should be complete emotional regulation to never feel any negative emotions, constant peace and tranquility. Because I think that's depriving ourselves of some of the useful things that any emotion, does for us, some of the useful things that panic does for us. I know that that sounds a little bit ridiculous, as uncomfortable as panic attacks are. I actually think that the worst thing we can do for ourselves, either before, during, or after is try and ignore it to avoid or suppress the sensations of anxiety and fear by rushing through, by distracting, by pushing them aside, because eventually
但我也认为，当我们谈论恐慌发作或任何可怕的情绪时，最终的目标不应该是彻底的情绪调节，即永远不感到任何负面情绪，获得持续的和平与宁静。因为我认为这是在剥夺我们一些任何情绪对我们有用的东西，剥夺恐慌对我们有用的东西。我知道这听起来有点荒谬，尽管恐慌发作让人很不舒服。实际上，我认为我们可以为自己做的最糟糕的事情，无论是在之前、期间还是之后，就是试图忽视它，通过匆忙行动、分散注意力、把它们推开来逃避或压抑焦虑和恐惧的感觉，因为最终
it will make them stronger. I think that's... seems really counterintuitive, especially if you're someone who has a panic disorder and you experience these very regularly, it is natural to have a lot of fear towards the incidence of and the prevalence of your panic attacks, right? Like, no one wants to be in a place where they're feeling this uncomfortable. And so naturally, we want to push them away. We want to run away. we want to put our panic, our panic attacks, our anxiety in this box and hide it and hope to never hear from it again. When we rely too heavily, though, on avoidance, especially when it comes to feelings of panic, this only causes us to focus on them more intensely. It also gives them more power because the act of fearing fear, which is essentially what you're doing by avoiding something, increases that fear.
这会让它们变得更强大。我认为这……看起来真的很反直觉，特别是如果你是一个有恐慌症并且经常经历这些的人，对恐慌发作的发生和普遍性产生很多恐惧是很自然的，对吧？就像，没有人想处于这种感觉不舒服的地方。所以自然地，我们想把它们推开。我们想逃跑。我们想把我们的恐慌、我们的恐慌发作、我们的焦虑放进这个盒子里藏起来，希望再也听不到它的消息。然而，当我们过分依赖回避时，特别是在面对恐慌的感觉时，这只会导致我们更强烈地关注它们。这也赋予了它们更多力量，因为害怕恐惧的行为——这本质上就是你通过回避某事所做的事情——会增加那种恐惧。
Now, I know that sounds very convoluted. But when we refuse to experience intense emotions like panic, we don't actually learn the skills to deal with them in the long run because we never have any practice. It also just causes them to return, I would say the best word is like to return stronger because every time we avoid thinking or feeling about our anxiety, it in many ways kind of returns with a vengeance because we never provide it with an outlet. And secondly, we never allow ourselves to truly acknowledge what might be triggering our fear,
现在，我知道这听起来非常费解。但是当我们拒绝体验像恐慌这样强烈的情绪时，从长远来看，我们实际上并没有学到应对它们的技能，因为我们从来没有任何练习。这也会导致它们卷土重来，我想最好的词是“卷土重来，变本加厉”，因为每次我们逃避思考或感受我们的焦虑时，它在很多方面都会带着复仇的怒火卷土重来，因为我们从未给它提供一个发泄的出口。其次，我们从来不允许自己真正承认是什么在触发我们的恐惧，
whether it's internal or external, because we are so scared of looking at our fear directly. We are so scared of examining it. Now, what is it that triggers a panic attack? Panic is what we call a survival emotion. It is a reaction that serves the function of preparing us to fight off or escape danger by creating and triggering a fear that is so strong that it prevents all rational and logical thinking. And it causes us to only really focus on that one thing in our environment or in our mind that we see is dangerous or threatening. So in this way, panic is the result of our fight or flight response.
无论是内在的还是外面的，因为我们太害怕直视我们的恐惧了。我们太害怕检查它了。那么，到底是什么触发了恐慌发作呢？恐慌是我们所说的生存情绪。它是一种反应，其功能是通过产生和触发一种极其强烈的恐惧，来阻止所有理性和逻辑思维，从而使我们准备好击退或逃离危险。并导致我们真正只关注环境中或大脑中我们认为危险或具有威胁性的那一个东西。所以从这个意义上说，恐慌是我们战斗或逃跑反应的结果。
This response is very evolutionary. It also now includes freeze and it's essentially the automatic urge we have. to address danger and ensure our survival by either fighting back against this force, whatever it may be, running away, or in some cases becoming paralyzed and being unable to really do anything. This is triggered by something that we see as dangerous. I think most people know this, obviously. This automatic response is for our survival. It came.
这种反应是非常进化的。它现在还包括僵住，这本质上是我们拥有的自动冲动。通过反击这种力量（无论它可能是什么）、逃跑，或者在某些情况下变得瘫痪而真正无法做任何事情，来应对危险并确保我们的生存。这是由我们认为危险的事情触发的。我想大多数人显然都知道这一点。这种自动反应是为了我们的生存。它来了。
It has developed for many, many, many generations. and in the past, the purpose that it served for our ancestors was that if there was a very real physical threat, like a big hungry lion or an incoming flood or a sinister neighboring tribe approaching us with weapons, we needed this panic to basically indicate to us to get away or to do something about it. Those were the threats that we faced when this automatic function and process first evolved and came about. nowadays these same triggers are still kind of present maybe not a lion i don't know where you're living though but more commonly these triggers can be anything that we perceive as dangerous sudden stressful or acute events but also a number of internal triggers phobias really bad dark thoughts certain stimulants
它已经发展了非常非常非常多代。在过去，它为我们的祖先服务的目的是，如果存在非常真实的身体威胁，比如一只饥饿的大狮子、即将到来的洪水，或者一个带着武器向我们逼近的邪恶邻近部落，我们需要这种恐慌基本上向我们发出信号，让我们逃跑或对此采取行动。当这种自动功能和过程最初进化和出现时，我们面对的就是这些威胁。如今，这些相同的触发因素仍然存在，也许不是狮子——我不知道你住在哪里——但更常见的是，这些触发因素可以是任何我们认为危险的事情，突然的、压力大的或急剧的事件，以及许多内部触发因素、恐惧症、非常糟糕的黑暗想法、某些兴奋剂
like caffeine ongoing stress many other things anything that evokes fear will as a result our fight or flight response because the part of us that is activating that response is not very intelligent. It is not rational. It is not, does not really have critical thinking skills. It is just meant to be there almost like an instantaneous alarm system. It is meant to be responding rapidly. And when something responds rapidly, as in this system, it doesn't have the time to really process what this thing that's scaring us really means. Whether it, it actually is truly dangerous. So when this automatic response is activated,
比如咖啡因、持续的压力等等，任何唤起恐惧的东西都会因此触发我们的战斗或逃跑反应，因为激活这种反应的那部分我们并不是非常聪明。它不是理性的。它不是、真的没有批判性思维能力。它只是意味着存在，几乎就像一个即时警报系统。它意味着快速反应。当某事做出快速反应时，比如在这个系统中，它没有时间真正处理吓唬我们的东西到底意味着什么。它是否真的具有真正的危险。所以当这个自动反应被激活时，
a particular part of our nervous system, known as our sympathetic nervous system, goes to work switching on all the bodily functions that we will need the most for immediate survival and switching off all of those that we don't need. So things like our digestive system, our sexual organs as a way to divert energy away from one thing, from one part of our body,
我们神经系统的一个特定部分，被称为我们的交感神经系统，开始工作，开启我们需要用于即时生存的所有身体功能，并关闭我们不需要的所有功能。所以像我们的消化系统、我们的生殖器官，作为一种将能量从一件事、从我们身体的一部分转移开的方式，
and put all of that energy to the systems that are going to help us with the threat in front of us. It floods us with neuropinephrine, with adrenaline, cortisol to get the body ready to fight, flee or freeze. And this subsequently triggers the symptoms that we associate with a panic attack. All of those bodily reactions are racing heart, sweating, dizziness, trembling, hot flushes, maybe that tingling in your arm, that tightness in your chest, a sense of imminent danger, spiraling thoughts. These sensations are caused by our body. They're caused by our involuntary response to danger.
并将所有这些能量投入到将帮助我们应对面前威胁的系统中。它向我们体内注入去甲肾上腺素、肾上腺素、皮质醇，让身体准备好战斗、逃跑或僵住。这随后会触发我们与恐慌发作联系在一起的症状。所有这些身体反应都是心跳加速、出汗、头晕、颤抖、潮热，也许手臂上有那种麻刺感，胸口有那种紧绷感，有即将发生危险的感觉，思绪翻江倒海。这些感觉是由我们的身体引起的。它们是由我们对危险的不自主反应引起的。
For example, that tingling sensation we were just talking about, that's actually caused by blood vessels constricting and increasing blood to the heart so that we can run faster, fight harder. But it also leaves less blood flow to the rest of the body, causing that strange feeling in our limbs. Those hot flushes that we often experience, that's just caused by an increase in body temperature because of the effect of those crucial stress hormones.
例如，我们刚才谈到的那种麻刺感，实际上是由血管收缩并增加流向心脏的血液引起的，这样我们就可以跑得更快、战斗得更努力。但这也会减少流向身体其余部分的血液，导致我们四肢出现那种奇怪的感觉。我们经常经历的那些潮热，只是由于压力荷尔蒙对身体的影响导致体温升高而引起的。
All of those sensations that we fear, that we associate with a panic attack, are nothing more than our body doing what it evolved to do best, which is to help us survive. But sometimes we actually misinterpret those sensations and we begin to think it means something more. It means something in our body has gone wrong. And that just causes our panic and our feelings. to accelerate. The biggest one for me is when my heart starts racing and I think for sure I'm going to have a heart attack. I'm going to die. I can't slow my heart right down. This big essential
我们害怕的所有那些感觉，我们与恐慌发作联系在一起的所有感觉，不过是我们的身体在做它进化得最好的事情，那就是帮助我们生存。但有时我们实际上误解了这些感觉，并开始认为这意味着更深层的含义。这意味着我们身体里的某个地方出了问题。而这只会加速我们的恐慌和感觉。对我来说最严重的一次是，当我的心脏开始狂跳，我确信我要心脏病发作了。我要死了。我无法让我的心脏慢下来。这个至关重要的
life-giving organ is going to burst in my chest. And what I know now is that that is the beginning of fearing the fear because I'm fearing the sensations. I'm not actually fearing the thing that cause those sensations in the first place. We get more worried about that than the actual danger. about our perception of danger. If you are someone who has a panic disorder, meaning you experience more frequent panic attacks of an increased severity, you also begin to fear having an attack at the wrong time,
给予生命的器官要在我的胸膛里爆裂了。而我现在所知道的是，那是开始害怕恐惧的开始，因为我在害怕这些感觉。我其实并不害怕最初引起这些感觉的事情。我们对危险的感知比对实际危险本身更担心。如果你是一个有恐慌症的人，这意味着你经历了更频繁、更严重的恐慌发作，你也开始害怕在错误的时间发作，
maybe during a lecture, at work, during a date, and this begins to become quite debilitating because you kind of have to fight back against that very instinctual, natural, normal urge to avoid those situations where you're going to feel exposed. You don't want to be in a public place or in front of other people and having this sense of fear.
也许在演讲期间、在工作中、在约会期间，这开始变得相当让人虚脱，因为你不得不与那种非常本能的、自然的、正常的冲动进行抗争，即避免那些你会感到暴露的Situations。你不想在公共场合或在其他人面前产生这种恐惧感。
And that can actually lead to anticipatory anxiety. And that is that kind of constant panic that you will have a panic attack, that you will experience a panic attack when it's inconvenient when you are unprepared. And the thing about panic attacks, specifically those caused by a panic disorder or even a phoenix disorder, or even a phobia, is that they are often directed towards things that don't pose an immediate threat that are not going to kill us, but that natural and instinctive alarm system has become broken so that it starts firing off warning signs and getting the body prepared for survival
这实际上会导致预期性焦虑。这就是那种持续的恐慌：你会恐慌发作，当你感到不便、没有准备好时，你会经历恐慌发作。关于恐慌发作的事情，特别是那些由恐慌症引起的恐慌发作，甚至是恐惧症引起的恐慌发作，它们通常针对的是那些不构成迫切威胁、不会杀死我们的事情，但那个自然和本能的警报系统已经坏了，所以它开始发出警告信号，让身体为生存做好准备，
in response to a whole array of triggers. Everybody has an internal alarm system that warns them. of when they are in danger. You need that. It's important. But with anxiety or a panic disorder, our alarm system has kind of become a bit miscalibrated, a bit faulty, way too sensitive, meaning that our threshold for what we should panic about is much lower than other people's. The analogy I think we talk about a lot is having a faulty car alarm, for example. You know, the normal car alarm should really only go off when someone is like out the side of your window with a baseball bat trying to steal your CDs. Like it should be triggered by things that are actually
以应对各种各样的触发因素。每个人都有一个内部警报系统，可以警告他们。当他们处于危险之中时。你需要这个。这很重要。但是有了焦虑或恐慌症，我们的警报系统已经变得有点校准错误、有点故障、过于敏感，这意味着我们应该恐慌的阈值比其他人低得多。我想我们经常谈论的比喻是有一个有故障的汽车报警器，例如。你知道，正常的汽车报警器真的只应该在有人像拿着棒球棒在你的窗户外试图偷你的CD时才响。就像它应该被那些实际上
going to like cause the car to break down or be broken into. But in the brain of someone with anxiety or a panic disorder, that alarm is a lot more sensitive. So using that car analogy, it could be triggered by a leaf falling on the roof. And that is enough to set everything off, to get everything going. I think knowing that that is what causes some people to panic more than others was really comforting to me. And there are a number of reasons that might cause this lowered threshold for emotional and physiological arousal. These include things like a family history of panic attacks. We know that genetics and DNA play such a huge role in a lot of mental health conditions, but also a past traumatic event that has caused you to become hypervigilant
会导致汽车抛锚或被砸的事情触发。但在患有焦虑症或恐慌症的人的大脑中，这个警报要敏感得多。所以用汽车的比喻，它可能被一片落在屋顶上的树叶触发。这就足以引发一切，让一切运转起来。我认为知道这就是导致有些人比其他人更恐慌的原因对我来说真的很安慰。导致这种情绪和生理唤醒阈值降低的原因有很多。这些包括诸如恐慌症家族史之类的事情。我们知道遗传学和DNA在许多心理健康状况中起着巨大的作用，还有过去曾导致你对周围环境和自身内部状态保持高度警惕的创伤事件，这几乎是一种生存技能，以避免该事件再次发生，避免未来的创伤。另一个例子是真正的重大生活变化或转变，它们已经从你身上夺走了如此多的能量，以至于几乎没有剩余的精神资源来应对小事情。这就是为什么我们经常看到有人可能正在经历像严重分手、离职、搬家，然后突然因为一件每个人都认为超级超级小的事情而恐慌发作，
to your surroundings and to your own internal state as almost a survival skill to avoid that event happening again, to avoid future trauma. Another example is really major life changes or shifts that are taking so much energy from you already that there are very few mental resources left over to cope with small things. That's why we often see someone who is maybe going through like a big breakup, they've left their job, they've moved, and then suddenly they're having a panic attack about something that everyone else would think is super, super minor,
比如找不到车钥匙或别人对他们说的一些小评论，因为他们没有足够的精神资源来应对这种额外的压力。不过，请记住，在那些时刻，这个警报系统试图做的是帮助你，而不是伤害你。你在那一刻的工作是有意识地解释这个系统是否弄错了，并纠正这种看法。我想提醒你的重要一点是，恐慌发作根本不可能永远持续下去。这在生理上是不可能的，我们会达到精疲力竭的点，对吧？它消耗了你太多的精力。大多数治疗师或心理学家会告诉你，恐慌发作可能在大约10分钟时达到顶峰。它最有可能、最肯定会在一小时内、大多数情况下在半小时内消退。有时很明显我们可以连续多次恐慌发作。所以会有一个简短的时期，你没有恐慌。有时我们会误解这一点，感觉
like not being able to find their car keys or some small comment that someone has said to them because they don't have the sufficient mental resources to deal with this added stress. remember in those moments though all this alarm system is trying to do is help you not harm you it's just your job in that moment to consciously interpret whether the system is getting it wrong and correct that perception the important thing i want to remind you is that panic attacks just cannot last forever it is not physically possible we will reach a point of exhaustion right? It's taking so much out of you. Most therapists or psychologists will tell you that a panic attack is probably going to peak around 10 minutes. It will most likely, most certainly subside within an hour, within half an hour most of the time. Sometimes obviously we can have multiple panic attacks in a row. So there'll be a small period where you're not panicking. Sometimes we can misinterpret that and feel
就像我们经历了一整天的恐慌发作，但人们会告诉你，这不是一次长期持续的恐慌发作，而是一次长期持续的恐慌发作，对不起，是多次较小的恐慌发作。不过，恐慌太消耗你的精力了。我们真的没有资源来维持这样一种感觉。这个向你发出警报、让你兴奋并引发你身体所有这些变化的系统，是为了短时间的能量爆发而设计的。所以随着时间的推移，所有这些，它消耗了你太多的精力，以至于你会耗尽。我其实觉得知道这一点真的很不错。你会挺过去的。你必须达到精疲力竭点或崩溃点。现在，你可能正在经历越来越多的
like we've had a panic attack for like a whole day, but people will tell you this is not one long continuous panic attacks, but one long, sorry, continuous panic attack, but multiple smaller panic attacks. Panic just takes so much out of you though. We genuinely do not have the resources to sustain such a feeling. This system that alarms you and sets you off and creates all of these changes in your body, it is meant for small concentrated bursts of energy. So over time, all that, it takes so much of your energy that you're going to run out. And I actually think that that's really nice to know. You will get through this. You have to reach an exhaustion point or a breaking point. Now, the reason you might be experiencing a greater
重复性恐慌发作，可能与你环境中的某件事或你内部状态中的某件事有关，这导致你感到不安全。它不一定需要是你环境中某种巨大的疯狂的、古怪的、非常明显的威胁。例如，也许两三年前有一段时间，我的恐慌发作很糟糕。它们太可怕了。它们太、太让人沮丧了。它们一直在失控地发生，而且似乎没有诱因。你知道，我会在床上，然后我会恐慌。我开始意识到的是，实际上当我回顾过去几个月时，它们一直非常、非常艰难。非常、非常难。我不知道我是否想深入探讨。这已经是过去了。所以也许我会给你一些细节。就像有
number of repetitive panic attacks, it might have to do with something in your environment or within your internal state that is causing you to feel unsafe. It doesn't necessarily need to be some big crazy, eccentric, you know, very obvious threat in your environment. For example, there was a time maybe two or three years ago where my panic attacks were terrible. They were awful. They were so, so frustrating. They happened all the time without control and also without seemingly a trigger. You know, I would be in bed and I would be panicking. What I began to realize was that actually the last few months when I looked back at them had been really, really rough. Really, really hard. I don't know if I want to go into it. And this was in the past. So maybe I will give you some detail. Like there had been
我的生活与朋友之间发生了很多冲突。我正在搬到一个新的城市。我从大学毕业了。我在和人们告别。我正在经历分手。我、我只是在慢慢被消磨殆尽。我也承担了很多朋友的问题。我意识到，当我开始，实际上在这个恐慌时期的尾声，这已经酝酿了一段时间。就像它一直在酝酿。这一直在慢慢酝酿，但我一直在压抑它，因为我只是觉得，我现在没有时间处理这个。我没有时间恐慌发作。我没有时间。我压抑这股浪潮的时间越长，当它最终冲破时，它就越强大。不过，关于恐慌和恐惧的一点是，尽管它们绝对是
a lot of conflict going on in my life with friends. I was moving to a new city. I was graduating from university. I was saying goodbye to people. I was going through a breakup. I was, I was just slowly being worn down. I was taking a lot of my friends problems on as well. And I realized when I started, actually at the tail end of this period of panic that this had been coming up for a while. Like this had been in the works. This had been slowly brewing, but I kept suppressing it because I just was like, I don't have time to deal with this right now. I don't have time for a panic attack. I don't have time. And the longer I held back that wave, the stronger it eventually was when it burst through. The thing, though, about panic and fear is that although they definitely are villainized
被妖魔化的，因为它们很不舒服，有时你实际上必须去感受它才能挺过去。从长远来看，推迟它只会让事情变得更糟。这有点像打地鼠，对吧？就像每次你看到恐慌发作的苗头冒出来，你都试图把它打下去，打下去。但如果你只是让它们冒出来，它们最终会消失。而且你会消耗更少的能量试图控制你环境中的一切，以确保你不会感到恐惧，而恐惧实际上是一种非常自然的反应。焦虑和恐慌实际上是有目的的。它可能表明出了什么问题，并且你无法达到稳态的状态或平衡。它可能会向你需要处理的持续压力源表明这一点。当我们看到那些根本没有这种恐惧反应的人时，
because they are uncomfortable, sometimes you actually just have to feel it to get through it. Putting it off is going to make it worse in the long run. It's almost like playing whackamol, right? Like every time you see like the nose of the panic attack popping out, you try and hit it down and hit it down. But if you just let them pop up, they'll eventually go away. And you'll exert less energy trying to control everything in your environment to ensure that you don't feel fear when fear is actually a really natural response. Anxiety and panic actually serves a purpose. It might indicate that something is wrong and that you're unable to reach a state or a balance of homeostasis. It might show you that there is an ongoing stressor that you need to deal with. And when we see people who don't have that fear response at all,
我总是想起亚历克斯·霍诺德（Alex Honnold），那位非常著名的徒手攀岩者。他是其中之一。这些人显然有一个更小的杏仁核，一个更小的大脑恐惧中心。他们不能总是识别危险。他们经常做危险的事情。他们也往往不能识别别人的情绪。通常是那些最焦虑的人也是最有同理心的。在某些方面，也许这是一个非常大的主张，但也是最聪明的，因为他们是那些坐在那里把一切都想透彻的人，
I always think about Alex Honnold, the very famous free-selling rock climber. He's one of them. These individuals obviously have like a smaller amygdala, a smaller fear center of the brain. And they can't always identify danger. They often do risky things. They can't always, as well, identify other people's emotions. It's often the people who are most anxious that are also the most empathetic. And in some ways, maybe this is a very big claim, but also the most intelligent, because they are the ones who are sitting there thinking everything through,
想着其他所有人是如何感受的，想着一切是如何出错的，所有这些灾难化。这有很多大脑锻炼就在那里。无论如何，无论恐慌和焦虑从科学的角度来看对我们人类有多么“功能性”，我确信如果你是一个经历过恐慌发作的人，你曾有过几个时刻，你愿意付出一切来过上没有它们的生活。它们很可怕，它们让人虚脱，它们太让人虚脱了，它们很不方便，我们不喜欢被一种我们无法控制的情绪所打扰。我懂的。我真的、真的很懂。我想谈谈我们如何将这种恐惧带回意识的、可操作的领域，也就是我们可以对此做些什么。我们如何管理我们的恐慌发作，使它们不会感觉像是那种会冲进来毁掉我们一切的独立实体？我想在短暂的休息后，为你提供一些我经过尝试和测试的建议，帮助你在这些时候回到地球和理性思考的自我。
thinking how everyone else is feeling, thinking how everything can go wrong, all of that catastrophizing. That's a lot of big brain exercises right there. regardless though of how quote unquote functional panic and anxiety might be to us as humans from a scientific point of view i'm sure that if you are someone who has panic attacks you have had a few moments where you would have given anything to live a life without them they're scary they're debilit they're so debilitating they're inconvenient we don't like feeling disrupted by an emotion that we can't control And I get that. I really, really get that. And I want to talk about how we can bring that fear back into the realm of what is conscious, what is actionable, something that we can do something about. How can we manage our panic attacks so they don't feel like this separate entity that is going to storm in and ruin everything for us? I want to provide you with some of my tried and tested tips for bringing you back down to earth and into your rational thinking self during these times.
也许你现在正处于恐慌时期，处于恐慌发作的深渊中。也许你可以把这个留到相关的时间。无论如何，在这次短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论我管理恐慌发作的五个基于证据的最佳建议。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及如何在充满压力的世界中培养适应力的科学。
Maybe you are in a period of panic right now in the depths of a panic attack. Maybe you can save this for a related time. Regardless, we're going to talk through five of my best evidence-based tips for managing panic attacks after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strain.
现代世界。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行交流，看穿主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字2%在I-Hart Radio应用程序上，
modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备讨论当天的快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们第二次讨论快克，所以我开始看到了一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。他们正在完成那句话。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. They're finishing that sentence.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上时做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任水平。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的I Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了明显的矛盾
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies
在她的故事中。这开始了长达多年的法庭斗争以证明真相。你伪造了。你伪造了。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctor. You doctor. I doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季度的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
Greg Alesspian and Michael Naranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。通常，当我们经历恐慌发作时，我们的第一直觉是反抗，因为那是我们对恐惧的自然反应。是反抗或回避来转移我们的注意力。我总是发现我立即，一感到那股恐慌的浪潮袭来，我立刻就会感到一种奇怪的、紧张的冲动，想要四处走动，从我坐的地方站起来，搬到一个新的空间，四处跑动，逃跑，告诉自己停下来，别想了，别想了，别想了。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Often when we are having a panic attack, our first instinct is to fight back because that is our natural reaction to fear. is to fight back or to avoid to distract ourselves. I always find that I immediately, as soon as I feel that like wave of panic coming on, I immediately like feel this weird jittery urge to move about, to get up from where I'm sitting, to move to a new space, to run around, escape, telling myself to stop, stop thinking about it, stop thinking about it, stop thinking about it.
但当你告诉自己不要去想它，不要去想任何事情时，这通常只会把更多的聚光灯投射到那件事上，因为它仍然是主体，所以停下来，别想这个，无论这是焦虑还是别的什么，仍然是那个想法的主要吸引力。这只会让我们更加意识到我们正试图逃避的感觉，随着时间的推移，试图逃避我们的恐惧，试图反抗它，试图逃跑，变得非常无效。恐慌发作很像流沙。你挣扎得越多，你陷入得就越深，麻烦就越大。
But when you're telling yourself to stop thinking about it, stop thinking about anything, normally that just puts more of a spotlight on that thing because it still remains the subject right stop thinking about this this whether that's anxiety whatever it is is still the main attraction of that thought it just makes us a lot more aware of the feeling that we are trying to escape and over time trying to flee our fear trying to fight back against it trying to escape it becomes really ineffective. Panic attacks are a lot like quicksand. The more you struggle, the further entrenched and in trouble you become.
所以你必须强迫自己做与身体告诉你的相反的事情，在这些情况下做高度反直觉的事情，并在其中放松下来。这只是一种感觉。这只是一种感觉。这只是恐惧。恐惧没有实体。它不会破门而入抓住你。它不会进入你的身体并关闭你的心脏并将你的四肢撕裂。
So you have to kind of force yourself to do the opposite of what your body is telling you to do, to do what is highly counterintuitive in these circumstances and relax into it. It is just a feeling. It is just a sensation. It's just fear. and fear does not have a physical form. It is not going to break through your door and grab you. It is not going to come into your body and shut your heart down and rip your limbs off.
所以你必须强迫自己去做身体本能反应的反面事情，在那种情况下做高度违反直觉的事，让自己放松下来。这只是一种感觉。这只是一种触感。这只是恐惧，而恐惧没有实体形态。它不会破门而入抓住你。它不会进入你的身体让你的心脏停止跳动并撕裂你的四肢。
Like it's simply a messenger for something that is going wrong or something that you need to address in your environment. I always like to give my anxiety 30 seconds to do whatever it wants to do when I'm about to have a panic attack. 30 seconds to ruin my life, to scream out loud, to cause my heart to stop. But when that's done, I'm going to move on. I'm giving my anxiety. I'm giving my panic attack, the reins. I'm giving it full control. I'm not trying to hide from it.
就像它只是某种出错的信使，或是你环境中需要解决的事情。每当我快要恐慌发作时，我总是喜欢给我的焦虑 30 秒的时间去做它想做的事。给它 30 秒来毁掉我的生活，大声尖叫，让我的心脏停止跳动。但当时间一到，我就会继续前进。我把焦虑、把恐慌发作的掌控权交了出去。我给予了它完全的控制权。我没有试图躲避它。
I'm not trying to give it more power than it deserves. I'm saying you can do your worst. You can try your hardest, whatever you have, throw it at me. And I often find that in those moments, it never leaves. lives up to what I thought it was going to do. It is like a small little yappy dog. It has a bark that is bigger than it's bite because it is just an emotion and emotions cannot hurt you. The other thing I like to do is to notice the feeling and then visualize it moving away. Visualize the feeling slowly dissolving whether that's being washed away by a tide or the other
我没有试图赋予它应得之外更多的力量。我对它说，你可以尽情使坏。你可以尽最大努力，无论你有什么招数，都冲我来吧。我经常发现，在那些时刻，它从来没有达到我预想中的那样。它就像一只爱乱叫的小狗。它的叫声比它的咬合力还要大，因为它只是一种情绪，而情绪是伤害不了你的。我喜欢做的另一件事是，注意到这种感觉，然后想象它正在移开。想象这种感觉慢慢消融，无论是被潮水冲走，还是另一个
one I like to think of is I'm holding my anxiety. I'm holding this trigger. I'm holding my fear. In my hand, it's a ball. It's a big baseball. It's a cricket ball. And I'm going to throw that ball as far away as I can and then I'm going to walk off. And all my fear is left with that object. All my fear is no longer mine to hold. It is in this tangible thing that is left that's left my body. When you notice the feeling and you give it a physical form that is not threatening, it's easier to see how it's in your control. I also find that focusing on those sensations that are very much aligned with a panic attack, very indicative of a panic attack, and choosing to just address one to begin with is really helpful because it takes,
我喜欢想象的场景是：我正握着我的焦虑。我正握着这个导火索。我正握着我的恐惧。它在我手里，是一个球。是一个棒球。是一个板球。我要把那个球扔得尽可能远，然后我要走开。我所有的恐惧都留在了那个物体上。我所有的恐惧不再属于我，而是留在了离开我身体的有形事物中。当你注意到这种感觉，并赋予它一种没有威胁的实体形态时，就更容易看出它是受你控制的。我还发现，专注于那些与恐慌发作高度契合、非常能说明恐慌发作特征的感觉，并选择先解决其中一个，真的很有帮助，因为这需要，
it actually lets me focus on one thing rather than feeling like there are a million things I need to do in order to calm down. When I just focus on one, firstly, once that's under control, the others will probably follow. And secondly, it almost distracts me from what I'm worrying about because I'm focusing on just fixing this one thing, whether that is your breathing and you need to do a really quick breathing exercise of a four in, four hold, four out, five in, five hold, five out, whatever it is, whether it is addressing that tingling sensation, that desire to run, that is basically just pent up energy coming from those stress hormones and from restricted blood flow that is in your body, you can find like a somatic and a physical outlet, give all of that
它实际上能让我专注于一件事，而不是觉得为了平静下来，有一百万件事需要去做。当我只专注于一件事时，首先，一旦这件事得到了控制，其他的事可能也会随之好转。其次，它几乎分散了我的注意力，让我不再去想让我担忧的事情，因为我只专注于解决这单一的事情，无论那是你的呼吸，并且你需要做一个非常快速的呼吸练习：吸气 4 秒、屏息 4 秒、呼气 4 秒，或者吸气 5 秒、屏息 5 秒、呼气 5 秒，无论是什么；无论它是解决那种刺痛感、想要逃跑的冲动——这基本上只是来自压力荷尔蒙和体内受限血流的蓄积能量——你都可以找到一个躯体和身体的宣泄口，给所有这些
nervous energy a place to go, whether that is going for a run, going boxing, doing 20 star jumps. Right now, 10 push-ups, I can't do 10 push-ups, but there you go. can try it. It just also shows your body that like, you're like, yeah, okay, you want me to do something about this. You're telling me that I'm in danger. I'll do something about it. I will move around. I will be physical. I will make sure that all of those extra hormones and all those stress hormones or neurotransmitters that you've got flooding through my body. They are serving a purpose. I'm going to do something about this trigger and it tricks the brain into calming you down. I also like to adopt the 5-5-5 rule. There are different iterations.
紧张的能量一个去处，无论是去跑步、打拳击、做 20 个开合跳。现在，做 10 个俯卧撑，我做不了 10 个俯卧撑，但你看，你可以尝试一下。这也向你的身体表明，你是说：“是的，好吧，你希望我对此做点什么。你告诉我我有危险。我会对此做点处理。我会四处走动。我会进行身体活动。我会确保你倾泻在我体内的所有那些额外荷尔蒙、所有那些压力荷尔蒙或神经递质都能发挥作用。我要对这个导火索采取行动”，这会欺骗大脑让你冷静下来。我也喜欢采用 5-5-5 规则。有不同的变体
of this. Sometimes it's the 5-4-3-2-1 rule, the 4-4-4-4 rule. But I always like to do the breathing exercise, or breathe in for 5, hold for 5, breathe out for 5. Identify five things that you can see that are a particular colour and five things that you can touch. And feel exactly how that fabric of that thing, that texture of that thing feels on your finger, feels on your body. Focus on something that is outside of you rather than the chaos and the hurricane of emotions that is within you. What this does is move you away from focusing on the fear and panic sensation, a feeling that is automatic and involuntary, and it gets you to focus on a sensation that you can control, something that you can bring into your orbit and do something about.
这种规则。有时它是 5-4-3-2-1 规则，或者是 4-4-4-4 规则。但我总是喜欢做呼吸练习，或者吸气 5 秒、屏息 5 秒、呼气 5 秒。找出你能看到的特定颜色的五样东西，以及你能触摸到的五样东西。去真切感受那种物体的织物、那种物体的质感在你的手指上、在你的身体上是如何感觉的。去关注你自身之外的事物，而不是你内心混乱和情绪飓风。这样做能让你不再专注于恐惧和恐慌的感觉——那是一种自动且不由自主的感觉——并引导你专注于一种你可以控制的感觉，一种你可以将其纳入你的轨道并采取行动的事物。
It's also why things like ice on your wrists or immediately putting something sour in your mouth, I always have wotheads with me, is really useful because your brain is like, wait a second, what is this weird feeling that is suddenly happening? Like, we need to focus on that because it's so shocking and out of the blue, like that intense cold or that intense sour taste. Really, like your brain cannot juggle too many stimulus or stimuli in the environment, too much information at once. So it needs to choose what to focus on. It's going to focus on the thing that just feels most immediate. And that might not be your panic if that, there is something else more pressing in your environment,
这也是为什么像手腕上敷冰块，或者立刻在嘴里放点酸的东西（我随身总是带着酸糖）会非常管用，因为你的大脑会想：“等一下，突然发生的这种奇怪感觉是什么？我们需要关注这个，因为它太震撼、太突如其来，”比如那种极致的冷或极致的酸味。真的，你的大脑无法同时应付环境中的太多刺激或刺激源、太多的信息。所以它必须选择专注于什么。它会专注于那种感觉最迫切的事情。如果环境中还有其他更紧迫的事情，那可能就不是你的恐慌，
like a really intense sensation that is going to drag you away from focusing on your fear. I also find that grounding exercises are incredibly useful, particularly ones that allow you to feel connected with nature. So going outside, taking your shoes off and putting your feet on the dirt, putting your feet in the grass, feeling how squishy it feels, how kind of dirty it feels, the tingling, the tickly sensation of the grass, feeling connected with nature. And we've seen study after study that has indicated that this naturally calms down our brain.
比如那种会把你从对恐惧的关注中拉开的强烈感觉。我还发现接地气（Grounding）练习极其有用，尤其是那些能让你感觉与大自然重新建立联系的练习。所以去户外，脱掉鞋子，把双脚踩在泥土上，把双脚踩在草地上，去感受它是多么松软，感觉它是多么有些泥泞，去感受草地那种微微发麻、刺痒的感觉，感受与大自然的连结。我们已经看到了一项又一项研究表明，这能自然地让我们的大脑平静下来。
Whether it's because of the wide open spaces give us a sense of like a place to escape to, whether the fresh air does something to bring us back to a state of like homeostasis into a feeling of a place of calm. One particular study that focuses on this says that the reason nature is such an important tool for integrative health but also for anxiety is that grounding and earthing in particular utilizes the electric charge from the earth and utilizes our nerve cells on the surfaces of our body to bring us into contact with the natural material and this as a result stabilizes a lot of that stress. it improves blood flow, it generates just a greatest sense of calm because we're focusing on what these things feel like for us. And it's bringing all that blood back into the nerves that are on our extremities rather than all concentrating on the heart and the lungs and the brain that's creating all that panic, that hot, flush sensation, that tingling. I feel like this goes
无论是由于开阔的空间给我们带来了一种可以逃离的地方感，还是新鲜空气发挥了某种作用，把我们带回了体内稳态的状态、带回了平静的感觉。一项专门关注此的研究表明，大自然之所以成为综合健康以及焦虑的重要工具，是因为接地和连地（Earthing）特别利用了来自地球的电荷，并利用我们体表的神经细胞使我们与自然物质接触，其结果是稳定了许多压力。它改善了血液循环，由于我们专注于这些东西对我们的感觉，它能产生最大程度的平静感。它把所有的血液重新带回四肢的神经中，而不是全部集中在心脏、肺部以及大脑上——而正是后者在制造所有那些恐慌、那种滚烫潮红的感觉、那种刺痛感。我觉得这
without saying, but if you are someone who is having a lot of panic attacks, I don't know what you're doing drinking caffeine or drinking alcohol excessively. Maybe that is all I need to say, but caffeine is a natural stimulant. And we don't often think about this. Alcohol as well has an anxious effect the morning after. Alcohol is a depressant. It does slow everything down. It might make you feel calm when you're drinking it. But the next morning, you're going to experience this huge spike in hormones and neurotransmitters that want to bring you back to that stable level. In the moment when you're drinking, it slows everything down. It releases these neurotransmitters and these hormones that really bring like almost a sense of calm. Really, it's just
不言而喻，但如果你是一个经常恐慌发作的人，我不知道你为什么还要摄入咖啡因或过量饮酒。也许这就是我需要说的全部了，但咖啡因是一种天然兴奋剂。我们往往不会这样想。宿醉的早晨，酒精也会产生焦虑效应。酒精是一种镇静剂。它确实会减慢一切。当你饮用它时，它可能会让你感到平静。但第二天早上，你将会经历荷尔蒙和神经递质的巨大飙升，它们试图把你带回那个稳定的水平。在你喝酒的当下，它减缓了一切。它释放了这些神经递质和荷尔蒙，确实带来了几乎一种平静感。真的，这只是
ethanol being processed by the body. The next morning, the next day, your body needs to bring back a sense of alertness. But because the sense of calm has been so intense, it kind of swings too far on the opposite direction, creating anxiety, contributing to panic attacks. Now, not everything is going to be entirely effective for you in managing this. Don't keep forcing habits or practices on yourself that don't work because you're just going to feel more frustrated and less in control because you're trying and not succeeding. I have a checklist in my phone of everything that I know works for me. And there are about, I think at this stage, over 30 things that I know I can do that are going to calm me down. So if the first one doesn't work, well, the second one probably will.
乙醇正在被身体代谢。第二天早上，第二天，你的身体需要恢复警觉感。但由于这种平静感如此强烈，它在反方向上摆动得太远了，从而产生了焦虑，并导致了恐慌发作。现在，并不是每一种方法对你管理这种情况都能完全奏效。不要总是把那些不管用的习惯或做法强加在自己身上，因为你只会感到更加沮丧、更失去掌控感，因为你尝试了却没有成功。我在手机里有一个清单，列出了所有我知道对我有用的方法。现在大概有、我想在这个阶段，有 30 多种我知道我能做、能让我平静下来的方法。所以如果第一个方法不管用，那么第二个方法很可能会管用。
And if that one doesn't work, I've got the third, fifth, all the way to 30 of options for me. And even the understanding and even like the fact that I know I have that list makes me feel so much better because I know that I have resources and options available that I'm not going to be stuck in that panicked moment because I've done that before. The biggest ones for me are meditations. I love going through my photo albums as a distraction, cleaning out all my photos. And I have my affirmations, my little reminders that I have survived this before. I will survive this now.
如果那个方法不管用，我还有第三个、第五个，一直到第 30 个备选方案。甚至这种理解，甚至“我知道我有这个清单”这一事实，都让我感觉好多了，因为我知道我有可用的资源和备选方案，我不会被困在那个恐慌的时刻，因为我以前经历过。对我来说最有效的方法是冥想。我喜欢翻看我的相册作为转移注意力的手段，清理我所有的照片。我还有我的积极肯定语，我小小的自我提醒：我以前在这种情况中幸存下来过。我现在也会幸存下来。
I am safe. I'm going to inhale the good thoughts, exhale the bad ones. And I'm just going to sit with that feeling for a little bit and give it a chance to hurt me. And after a while, I realize that it won't. It won't hurt me. The final thing that really helps me that I return to again and again in my own life are these short five-minute visualization exercises that I can put on, listen to, and I find it really calms me down.
我是安全的。我要吸入美好的想法，呼出糟糕的想法。我只想和那种感觉共处一会儿，给它一个伤害我的机会。过了一会儿，我意识到它不会。它不会伤害我。最后一件真正对我帮助很大、在我的生活中一再回用的事情，是这些简短的五分钟可视化练习，我可以播放、聆听，我发现它真的能让我平静下来。
I even imagine them when I don't have immediate access to that audio, like on a plane or someone without Wi-Fi or an internet. So I want you to pause with me for a second. And we're going to go through one together. right now. I know that right now it feels like your panic is taking over. That's okay. Remember, it is just a feeling, no different to feeling joyful or frustrated or happy or angry. These emotions exist only within you and your panic is not going to hurt you. It is not physical. It has come from you and therefore you can control it. I'm here.
甚至当我无法直接接触到该音频时，比如在飞机上，或者在没有 Wi-Fi 或互联网的地方，我也会想象它们。所以我希望你和我一起暂停一秒钟。我们现在要一起做一个练习。我知道现在感觉你的恐慌正在接管你。没关系。记住，这只是一种感觉，与感到快乐、沮丧、开心或生气没有什么不同。这些情绪只存在于你的内心，你的恐慌是不会伤害你的。它不是实体存在的。它源于你，因此你可以控制它。我就在这里。
with you now in this moment and you and I are like partners. I'm going to watch out for you whilst you take some time to realign all of your senses, make sense of this feeling and in only a few minutes you're going to be able to return to whatever it is you were just doing. Don't worry about what's going on around you. I can do that for you. All I need you to focus on right now is your body and what your feeling. I want you to focus on your breathing with me. We're going to breathe in for five seconds now. Five, four, three, two, one. Now hold for five, four, three, two, one, and breathe out for five seconds. Good job. I knew that wouldn't be too hard. I want you to pause for a second and repeat that three more times. I'm sure you're feeling better now. I can see that. Good job. I'm proud of you.
现在这一刻和你在一起，你和我就像是伙伴。我会照顾你，而你花点时间重新调整你所有的感官、理解这种感觉，只需短短几分钟，你就能回到你刚才在做的事情上去。不要担心你周围发生了什么。我可以为你代劳。现在我只需要你专注于你的身体和你的感受。我希望你和我一起专注于呼吸。我们现在吸气五秒钟。五，四，三，二，一。现在屏息五秒，四，三，二，一，然后呼气五秒。干得好。我知道这不会太难。我希望你暂停一秒钟，再重复三次。我相信你现在感觉好多了。我看得出来。干得好。我为你感到骄傲。
Now I want you to focus on your heartbeat for a few seconds and you take a few more deep breaths. Just notice how it begins to slow down. You're doing that because you're in control. Your anxiety doesn't have as much control as it would like. You are the one in charge. You're a bit like a scientist in this moment. I want you to think of this panic you're feeling as an interesting specimen you want to understand better. It's sitting right in front of you,
现在我要你把注意力集中在心跳上几秒钟，再做几次深呼吸。只需注意它是如何开始放慢的。你这样做是因为你在掌控之中。你的焦虑并没有它想象的那么强的控制力。你才是掌权者。此时此刻，你有点像个科学家。我希望你把你感受到的这种恐慌看作是一个你想更好地了解的有趣标本。它正坐在你面前，
behind a nice, reinforced pain of glass. It can't hurt you, it can't touch you, but you can observe it. And notice what it's responding to. as you relax it will too and if you can't that is okay you can always walk out of the room and leave your anxiety behind it is not going to escape it's not going to hurt you because you are in control you have the key and you alone to test this i want you to give your anxiety 30 seconds to break free 30 seconds to try and escape, to take over, to do its worst.
在一块经过加固的漂亮玻璃后面。它伤害不了你，它碰不到你，但你可以观察它。并注意它在对什么做出反应。当你放松时，它也会放松；如果你做不到，那也没关系，你随时可以走出房间，把你的焦虑留在身后。它不会逃跑，它不会伤害你，因为你在掌控之中。你拥有钥匙，而且只有你拥有。为了检验这一点，我希望你给你的焦虑 30 秒的时间来挣脱，30 秒的时间去尝试逃跑、去接管、去尽情使坏。
You're being really generous with your anxiety. You don't have to do this for it, but you are deciding to be kind today. You're going to look at your anxiety right now and say, okay, it's your turn, do whatever you would like, destroy the room, jump around, whatever you want to do. But after 30 seconds, you have had to have. had your chance and now it's my turn. So let's count down together. Okay. 30, 29, 28, 27, 26, 25, 24. You might feel like your anxiety is fighting very hard right now to get out of that room, but it's still trapped behind that glass while you're sitting calmly in the
你对你的焦虑真是太慷慨了。你本不必为它这么做，但你决定今天表现得善良一些。你现在要看着你的焦虑说：“好吧，轮到你了，做你想做的事吧，把房间砸了，到处乱跳，随便你想干什么。”但在 30 秒之后，你必须已经把握住了你的机会，现在轮到我了。所以让我们一起倒数。好。30，29，28，27，26，25，24。你可能会觉得你的焦虑现在正在拼命挣扎，想要逃出那个房间，但它依然被困在那块玻璃后面，而你正平静地坐在
nice comfortable chair watching each of its moves not needing to react 23 22 21 20 20 19 18 your anxiety is getting tired now you can see it losing its steam it knows it's not going to win this time or the next it's slowly losing its energy. 17, 16, 15, 14, 13, 13, 13, 12, 12, 11, 11, 11, 10. Your anxiety has run out of energy. It's not screaming or yelling anymore. It is slowing down, its eyes are closing. nine, eight, seven, six, five. There's your anxiety sitting calmly in the corner. Four, three, two, one.
舒适的椅子上，看着它的每一个动作，不需要做出反应。23，22，21，20，20，19，18。你的焦虑现在开始累了。你可以看到它在失去干劲。它知道这一次或下一次它都不会赢。它正在慢慢失去能量。17，16，15，14，13，13，13，12，12，11，11，11，10。你的焦虑已经耗尽了能量。它不再尖叫或大喊了。它慢了下来，它的眼睛正在闭上。9，8，7，6，5。看，你的焦虑正平静地坐在角落里。4，3，2，1。
Now, it's your time. Focus on your breath again for me. breathe in again for five four three two one now we're going to hold and finally breathe out with me five four three two one if you need to you can do that a few more times it's always going to be up to you as you continue to breathe deeply i want I want to remind you that you are safe and supported in this moment. Panic attacks can be overwhelming, but you have the strength within you to overcome them, like you just did. Remember to be gentle with yourself and to acknowledge those feelings.
现在，轮到你了。再次为我专注于你的呼吸。再次吸气，五，四，三，二，一。现在我们屏息，最后和我一起呼气，五，四，三，二，一。如果你需要的话，你可以多做几次。这完全取决于你。当你继续深呼吸时，我想提醒你，在这一刻你是安全且被支持的。恐慌发作可能会让人不堪重负，但你的内心拥有克服它们的坚强力量，就像你刚才做的那样。记得对自己温柔一些，并承认那些感受。
You are so capable and brave and strong and I am so proud of you. I want you to talk to your panic now. talk to your anxiety. You can see, really, that it's just this weak little creature sitting in the corner of the room. You feel slightly sorry for it and you're going to speak to it with compassion.
你是如此能干、勇敢和坚强，我为你感到无比骄傲。现在我想让你和你的恐慌谈谈。和你的焦虑谈谈。你可以看到，其实它只是坐在房间角落里的一个虚弱的小生物。你对它有点同情，你将带着同理心与它对话。
I know you're scared anxiety and that's okay. I'm going to be gentle with you. You can be at peace here. Nothing is wrong. We are alive. We are breathing. We are loved.
我知道你很害怕，焦虑，没关系。我会对你温柔以待。你可以在这里获得平静。一切都很好。我们还活着。我们在呼吸。我们被爱着。
and you are welcome here. I know that you have been misunderstood in the past. I know I've been scared of you, but I can see that under that scary exterior, you are just an emotion trying to be seen. I see you. I acknowledge you. You can stay here for a while,
并且这里欢迎你。我知道你过去一直被误解。我知道我曾害怕过你，但我能看出，在那个吓人的外表下，你只是一种渴望被看见的情绪。我看见你了。我承认你的存在。你可以留在这里一会儿，
but in exchange, you don't get to be in control. I'm in control. So feel free to get comfy, to rest. let me know if you need anything and we can talk again but for now i'm going to leave this room and get on with my day i'm going to leave in three two one goodbye anxiety are you feeling better i really hope so and if not please feel free to listen again when we visualize our anxiety as something that is harmless something that we can see we can hold that we can approach.
但作为交换，你不能拥有控制权。我在掌控一切。所以请随意感到舒适、休息。如果你需要什么随时告诉我，我们可以再聊，但现在我要离开这个房间，继续过我的一天了。我要在三、二、一中离开。再见，焦虑。你感觉好点了吗？我真心希望如此。如果没有，当你需要时，请随时再次收听。当我们把焦虑想象成无害的东西、我们可以看到的东西、我们可以握住和接近的东西时，
We release a lot of that additional fear we have around what it can do to us, the harm it can cause. Because at the end of the day, something that we forget is that it is just another emotion and you are the house, the home of all of these emotions. They are you. You have the final say. I really hope that this episode helped you, just giving you more information about what panic attacks actually are guiding you through what to do about it, some of my tactics
我们释放了围绕着它会对我们做什么、它可能造成的伤害的大部分额外恐惧。因为归根结底，我们容易忘记的是，它只是另一种情绪，而你是所有这些情绪的房屋、家园。它们就是你。你拥有最终决定权。我真心希望这一期节目对你有所帮助，为你提供了更多关于恐慌发作到底是什么的信息，引导你了解该如何应对，分享了一些我的策略
and my tips providing you with that psycho education. I hope you're just feeling better. I hope that if you need to return to this episode that you do, it will always be here. Feel free to come back. I will still be here eternally in this little voice, in this little episode clip. But if there is someone you know who might need to hear this,
和我的诀窍，为你提供心理健康教育。我希望你现在感觉好些了。我希望如果你需要重听这一期节目，你会回来的，它永远都会在这里。随时欢迎回来。我将永远在这个小小的声音、这个小小的节目剪辑中陪伴着你。但如果你认识的人可能需要听听这个，
please feel free to share it with them. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review wherever you are listening right now. If you liked this episode, I know it's a bit different to what I usually do. Please let me know if it was of any help, if you would like me to do more episodes like this. You can DM me over on Instagram at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you.
请随时分享给他们。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随时在你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你喜欢这一期节目——我知道这和我平时的风格有点不同——请让我知道它是否有任何帮助，如果你希望我做更多这样的节目。你可以在 Instagram 上私信我，账号是 that psychology podcast。我很期待听到你的声音。
I'm sending you love. I'm sending you strength. I'm proud of you. Good job. You got through it. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an essay.
我向你发送爱。我向你发送力量。我为你感到骄傲。干得好。你挺过来了。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、体能的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗挫力的秘诀。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 IHeart Radio 苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。
escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back At It”。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难中学习》（Learn The Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在其他地方进行这些对话其实并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难中学习”。
Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子都炸了。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客收听“深陷爱河”播客，
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
或在你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。